there are so many new Beauty releases  happening all the time so we gathered  some of the most hyped products to test  for ourselves this is the KVD Dazzle  long wear eyeshadow stick I was really  surprised at how soft this formula is  this is packed with glitter and Shimmer  and it just looks so pretty on the eyes  I tried a couple products from the K  Beauty brand romand this glitter palette  has been raved about overall I would say  the formulas are on the dry side but  they were actually pretty easy to work  with I had no problem swiping or patting  them on and I had little to no Glitter  Fallout I also tried the glassing water  tint the color and gloss are separate  layers so you get that long lasting tint  with a glossy finish they're really  lightweight and they definitely do leave  a stain look at my hand after I wipe  those swatches off